Fox's hit musical dramedy "Glee" made fans laugh,
cry, and sing along for six award-winning seasons.
But not all of the performers who brought
the show to life are still with us today.
Cory Monteith played Finn Hudson, an all-American
jock with a sensitive side and soothing voice.
Finn's on-again, off-again relationship with
Lea Michele's Rachel Berry was a centerpiece
of the show's dramatic moments, earning
the affectionate portmanteau "Finchel."
However, Monteith came to the Glee cast with some
weighty personal struggles. In a 2011 interview
with Parade, the Canadian actor opened up
about his battle with drugs and alcohol,
which began when he was just 13 years old.
By the time he was 19, Monteith's friends and
family organized an intervention, after which
the actor entered rehab for the first time.
Unfortunately, Monteith's demons continued
to haunt him throughout his 20s. According
to E! Online, he entered rehab again in 2013,
completing the program at the end of April. Then,
on July 14, news broke that Monteith was
found dead in his Vancouver hotel room.
Autopsy results revealed that the actor
died of an accidental overdose of heroin and
alcohol with traces of codeine and morphine
also found in his blood. The third episode
of the fifth season of Glee, titled "The
Quarterback," was dedicated to Monteith.
"Everyone wants to talk about how he died too,
but who cares? One moment in his whole
life, I care more about how he lived."
Every show about high school needs a "bad boy."
For Glee, that was Mark Salling's character,
Noah "Puck" Puckerman. Salling appeared in
the show for the entirety of the series,
though he was only a recurring
character for its final two seasons.
Much like Shakespeare's character of the
same name, Puck was a mischief-maker,
albeit a lovable one. As the
series' resident deviant,
Puck was known for his sexual exploits
and violent tendencies. Like his co-star
Cory Monteith, Salling also found
himself in unflattering headlines.
In 2013, Salling's ex-girlfriend,
Roxanne Gorzela, sued the Texas native,
alleging he forced her to have unprotected
sex. Though Salling denied the accusations,
TMZ reports he paid Gorzela a
settlement of $2.7 million out of court.
A few months after Glee ended,
Salling was arrested and charged
with possession of child pornography. When
authorities searched his California home,
they discovered more than 50,000 images of
child pornography on his computer. Salling
pleaded guilty in December 2017, with
sentencing set for March 2018. Likely
facing several years in prison, Salling died by
suicide in January 2018. He was 35 years old.
Jane Lynch is one of only five Glee actors to
star in a main role for all six seasons of the
show. As Sue Sylvester, head coach of William
McKinley High School's cheerleading squad,
Lynch played the show's villain.
Typically clad in a tracksuit,
Sylvester stalked the halls of McKinley,
instilling fear in both students and staff.
Despite her edges, however, Sue also
had a soft spot for Becky Jackson,
a McKinley student with Down's
syndrome who she took under her
wing. Though her affection for
Becky seems out of character,
viewers eventually learn that Sue has an older
sister, Jean, who also has Down's syndrome.
"There's really only one person
in the world I wanna impress."
"Who?"
"Who? You silly!"
Robin Trocki, who came to Glee with no
acting experience, played Jean Sylvester
in five episodes throughout Seasons 1 and 2.
Trocki died in 2019 from Alzheimer's disease
at the age of 63. While not a star of
the series, Trocki's involvement with
Glee helped raise awareness for Down's
syndrome in a nearly unprecedented way.
For the first season of Glee, Naya Rivera
played the recurring character Santana Lopez,
one of Sue's top cheerleaders, before being
promoted to the show's main cast in Season2.
Just as Mark Salling's character filled
the role of "bad boy," Rivera's character
served as the "mean girl," though
that persona softened over time.
In addition to providing powerful vocals
in New Directions, Santana also added to
the show's LGBT sensibilities. Early in the
series, Santana is revealed to be bisexual,
and in Season 6 she marries fellow
glee club alum Brittany Pierce.
In July 2020, Rivera took her 4-year-old son
on a pontoon boat in California's Lake Piru.
When Rivera failed to return the rental boat at
the appointed time, a team was sent to locate
the boat and its passengers. When the boat
was found, only Rivera's son was onboard.
The child told authorities that after a swim,
his mother helped him back onto the boat
before she slipped beneath the water's
surface and disappeared. After an exhaustive
and multi-day search, the Ventura County
Sheriff's Office announced the discovery
of Rivera's body. According to E! Online,
an autopsy concluded that Rivera died as a result
of accidental drowning. She was 33 years old.
Billed as "Ancient Librarian," Jean Sincere
appeared in three episodes of Glee during
its first and second seasons. Her role
largely consisted of either shushing or
glaring at the glee club members as they
broke into exuberant songs in her library.
However, in Season 1's Bad Reputation,
the librarian responds to a performance
of "U Can't Touch This" by suggesting
that the club members recreate the song
for the Sunday service at her church.
The role of the Ancient Librarian was typical of
Sincere's television career, which began in the
late 1940s and concluded in 2012 with a guest
appearance on iCarly. A trained stage actress,
Sincere made her debut on Broadway in the
1941 production of Arsenic and Old Lace,
and appeared in other shows before
touring Europe as part of the USO.
After nearly three decades away from
television, Sincere returned to the
small screen in a 1985 episode of Cagney and
Lacey and moved into steady work as a guest
player in series like Newhart, Murphy
Brown, and Everybody Loves Raymond.
She also made occasional
forays into feature film work,
the most memorable of which was her
voice-acting role as the elderly Mrs.
Hogenson, whom Bob Parr helps with an
insurance claim in The Incredibles.
"I'm on a fixed income!"
Sincere remained active on television
and local theater into her ninth decade
and died of natural causes at
the age of 93 on April 3, 2013.
Though some critics were not impressed by
"The Rocky Horror Glee Show," the Season 2
tribute to Richard O'Brien's enduring
cult musical, fans of the 1975 film
version were undoubtedly happy to see
two of its stars appear in minor roles.
Barry Bostwick, who played Brad in The
Rocky Horror Picture Show, and Meat Loaf,
who played Eddie in both the film and the
original Broadway production, feature as
managers of a local news station who plot with Sue
Sylvester to produce an expose on the school play.
Born Marvin Lee Aday, singer Meat Loaf
enjoyed chart success in three different
decades as well as a second career as
an actor. His success on the pop and
rock charts was largely anchored around
the Bat Out of Hell album trilogy. Some
of the hits off these records include the
epically scaled "Paradise By the Dashboard
Light," and the Grammy-winning "I'd Do
Anything for Love (But I Won't Do That").
As an actor, Meat Loaf's best-known role
outside of Rocky Horror was as Robert Paulson,
the sympathetic ex-weightlifter in
David Fincher's Fight Club. However,
he also appeared in Wayne's World and The
Salton Sea, and made guest spots on shows
like Masters of Horror and Elementary.
After experiencing several health issues
in the 2000s, he died at the age of 74 in
Nashville, Tennessee on January 20, 2022.
The character Pete Sosnowski presided
in part over the 2010 Western Ohio
Sectionals Championship in Season 2's
"Special Education." This character,
played by veteran actor Mike Hagerty, is
probably best known as the man who announced
that the New Directions and the Warblers tied
for first place at that year's competition.
A Chicago native and member of its famed improv
troupe, The Second City, Hagerty began appearing
in minor and supporting roles in both TV
and movies in the early '80s. A go-to for
overworked and easily aggravated blue-collar
types, Hagerty played cops, truck drivers,
salesmen, and furniture movers on classic sitcoms
such as Married... with Children and Cheers.
By the mid-'90s, Hagerty had moved up
to supporting roles, which included his
best-known small screen characters: grumpy
building supervisor Mr. Treeger on Friends
and the owner of a vintage clothing store
who butted heads with Kramer in Seinfeld.
Hagerty remained active well into
the new millennium with recurring
roles in Lucky Louie and Brooklyn Nine-Nine.
"What the hell's going on around here?"
"Fire extinguisher roller chair derby?"
"Okay."
He also co-starred in the HBO
comedy Somebody Somewhere. TMZ
reported that after completing
the latter show's first season,
Hagerty experienced a seizure due to an adverse
reaction to antibiotics and lapsed into a
coma. The 67-year-old died at Los Angeles'
Cedars-Sinai Medical Center on May 5, 2022.
Singer and actress Olivia Newton-John
parodied her own squeaky-clean image
in two appearances on Glee. In Season
1's "Bad Reputation," she helped repair
the damage done to Sue Sylvester's
status and dignity after a bootleg
video of her performing Newton-John's
"Physical" was leaked to the internet.
To help Sue save face, Newton-John
appeared alongside her in an almost
exact duplicate of the song's original campy music
video. She later returned that same
season for "Journey to Regionals",
in which she played a self-centered judge for the
New Directions' performance at the competition.
Born in England but raised in Australia,
Newton-John enjoyed considerable success
in two mediums throughout the 1970s and 1980s.
As a singer, she earned 15 Top 10 singles on
Billboard's Hot 100 chart, including five No. 1
hits like "I Honestly Love You" and "Physical."
In addition to topping the charts, she also
earned 12 Grammy nominations and four wins.
Newton-John's success as a singer also
led to an acting career that included
the staggering box office hit Grease — which
also generated three Top 10 hits — and Xanadu.
Diagnosed with breast cancer in 1992, Newton-John
became a tireless advocate for research and
treatment. The disease returned in 2017 and
metastasized to her back and bones.Newton-John
died at the age of 73 at her home in the Santa
Ynez Valley in California on August 8, 2022.
Emmy-winning comic actor Tim Conway
joined fellow performing vets Billy
Dee Williams and June Squibb for Season
5's "Old Dog, New Tricks." The episode,
which was penned by cast member Chris Colfer,
gave its three guest stars a few moments to
shine as residents at a home for retired actors
who are producing a stage version of Peter Pan.
Conway began in regional television in the
late 1950s before earning his first break
on The Steve Allen Show. A co-starring role on
McHale's Navy led to several attempts to craft
a TV series around him, but Conway always
seemed to fare best as a supporting player.
He was a hilarious improviser who frequently
reduced his castmates on The Carol Burnett Show
to hysterics, and teamed with another peerless TV
comic, Don Knotts, in a string of '70s features
for Walt Disney Pictures. Conway was also an
in-demand guest star on numerous series like
Coach and 30 Rock, for which he won two additional
Emmys. He was also a popular voice-over actor for
animated projects, most notably voicing
Barnacle Boy in SpongeBob SquarePants.
In 2018, Conway was diagnosed with dementia
due to normal pressure hydrocephalus,
a condition that causes cerebrospinal
fluid to build up in the brain. He died
from complications from the condition at the
age of 85 in Los Angeles on May 14, 2019.
Best known as the creator, writer, and host
of the long-running Bravo and Ovation series
Inside the Actors Studio, James Lipton
appeared on Glee's Season 3 finale,
"Goodbye." The episode, which concerned
the graduation of eight Glee club members,
saw Finn audition for Lipton in order to
win a spot at the prestigious Actors Studio.
That same year, Lipton also interviewed several
Glee cast members and co-creator Ryan Murphy on
an episode of the Actors Studio series.
Inside the Actors Studio was the product
of Lipton's work as the dean of the Actors
Studio Drama School, a graduate program for
actors that united the Actors Studio
with New York's New School University.
As part of its curriculum, Lipton recorded
interviews with actors, directors,
and writers about their crafts. These interviews
began airing on Bravo in 1994, and the show's
success vaulted Lipton to pop culture stardom. The
host soon parlayed his success into appearances,
most often as himself, in series like
The Simpsons and Saturday Night Live.
Lipton was also an actor himself for a time,
beginning his career in radio during the
1940s and making appearances on Broadway
and television during the 1950s. He segued into
writing for television series like The Guiding
Light and specials for comedian Bob Hope, as
well as several novels and Broadway musicals.
He remained with Inside the Actors Studio until
2018, earning 18 Emmy nominations during the
show's 24-year run. Lipton died of bladder
cancer at the age of 93 on March 2, 2020.